ام
[موسيقى]
اعتلى الخليفه عمر بن الخطاب رضي الله عنه
المنبر وخطب في الناس فطلب منهم الا
يغالوا في مهور النساء ل ان رسول الله صلى
الله عليه وسلم واصحابه لم يزيدوا في ظهور
النساء عن اربعمائه درهم ولما نزل عمر من
على المنبر قالت له امراه مسلمه يا امير
المؤمنين اما سمعت قول الله تعالى واتيتم
احداهن قنطارا اي المال الكثير فقال عمر
اللهم اغفر انه ثم رجع في صعد المنبر وخطب
يا ايها الناس اني كنت نهيتكم ان تزيدوا
في مهور النساء فمن شاء ان يعطي من ماله
ما احب فليفعل
ولم يقل عمر للسيده بانها تهدد الامن
القومي وتطيح بسمعه وهيبه رئيس الدوله ال
قال لها كل الناس افقه من عمر الى
العناوين
لا عهده خمسه تمديد
مساجدنا ثكناتنا
مره اخرى
المصريين يوم القيامه
في كوريا الشماليه
نعم نعم
في
القاهره
صحيح البخاري
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
مرحبا ها قد عدنا لسان حاله يقول في سعد
وسعد هي المدينه التركيه التي ردد فيها
رئيس بلديه اسطنبول رجب اردوغان هذه
الابيات سجن بتهمه معاداه العلمانيه بعد
واحد وعشرين عاما عاد اليها اردوجان رئيسا
للجمهوريه
ليرد فيها نفس القصيده وبيت القصيد لكم
دينكم وليا دين في هذا الوقت كانت واشنطن
تهدد انقره على طريقه انا او الضرر ان
طائراتنا الحميده واما صواريخ بوتين
الخبيثه فرد اردوغان الصفقه مع موسكو تمت
والبيع مكتمل الاركان
حذرنا تركيا بوضوح من ان احتمالا
اربعمائه سيؤدي الى اعاده تقييم مشاركه
تركيا في برنامج المقاتله خمسه وثلاثين
انهينا صفقه منظومه الصواريخ
اربعمائه ولا يمكننا ترجع ابدا بيونغ يانغ
مشكلتها اكبر مع واشنطن اذا صح انها تعيد
بناء موقع للصواريخ لكن لهجه الرئيس
ومن حوله وهو يعيش في كوكبه الخاص
[موسيقى]
[ضحك]
[تصفيق]
هذا التصفيق الهلع كان بمناسبه ظهور
المهدي اثناء عبوره المزيد ل ادلائه بصوته
الرشيد في ابها مظاهر الاستراليه
الاشتراكيه الديمقراطيه بالخلطه الكوريه
تصويتكم وشعبه الوفي كان ل انتخابات
تشريعيه نموذجيه بلغت نسبه التصويت فيها
رسميا تسعه وتسعين فاصل تسعه وتسعين
بالمائه لا يوجد فيها الا مرشح واحد عن كل
دائره اذا كنت محض يا بالجنسيه الكوريه
الشماليه تصوت له بنعم او كله ونعمك
اولائك فيها نعيمك او بلائك انتخب بضمير
عندكو لا تبدا تعيش الكوريون الشماليون
ينتخبون نواب مجلس الشعب الاعلى الذي يعد
السلطه التشريعيه العليا في البلاد وفي
هذه الانتخابات يدلي الناخبون باصواتهم
لمرشح وحيد لعضويه المجلس في كل دائره
انتخابيه و يقتصر تصويتهم على نعم اولى
سيده كوريه شماليه خبره الحياه وخلصت الى
هذه النتيجه اعتقد ان بلدنا هو الوحيد
الذي يحتفل بيوم الانتخابات وكانه يوم
اطلع سابذل قصارى جهدي من اجل النظام
الاشتراكي لبلدنا انه الافضل في العالم و
ساؤيد بكل اخلاص قائدا الاعلى
هذا الامام الكوري بالرئيس الا يستاهل
الرئيس السياسي مثله في مصر لماذا يتركه
المصريون دائما في حاله شك بحبهم وب
ولائهم مع انه من فرط حبه لهم يعدل
الدستور ليبقى معهم كل العمر كله
المصريين
الله
والله انا المشكله الكبيره اللي موجوده
معايا انا ان شاء الله رجل صادق
مشكله كبيره جدا تعرفون عني صادقا
وامينا وان شاء الله وشريف ان شاء الله
ارحل يا سيسي بعد كل هذا الدلال والرفاه
والحريه ارحل يا سيسي هو انا وعدتكم
فاخلفتكم
هون او تلك معاي السمنه والعسل بعدم ولكن
هناك لتصريحاته
صغيره العدد
لانه احنا بنعمل شو نصف ما اعرف يعني
بهذا ال
يعني اللي بعرفه سيكولوجيه الدكتور
الفلسطينيه
لا ان شاء الله كل كل واحد
اه يعني
مع بعض اذا كان الامير بن سلمان يضع خطه ل
عشرين ثلاثين فلس يستغل على عشرين ستين
قسما بالله كان كان يوم بيقولولنا حيحصل
مشكله بالحسابات والعلم الفين وسته الفين
وسته يعني حكون موت موت قلت لهم قسما
بالله لا لا لا بد من التصدي ولا نترك
لاجيالنا الخراب والضياع
الوقتي ونعمل لها صندوق مشكله دكتور احمد
موسى يبكي من كثر الايمان الجيش والشرطه
اخواننا في بلد عظيمه عندها جيش وعندهن
شرطه فخور جيش وشرطه وشعبي مخيف والله لا
اخشى عليكم من الخارج ابدا
والله والله والله انا اخشى عليكم من
الداخل فقط من انفسنا ما فيش تهديد خارج
تخاف منه انا بشكرك
منكم انتم
خالد يوسف النائب مخرج المصري المعارض
لتحنيط رئاسه السياسي بشرب ان النظام
السياسي سينتهي ولو بعد حين العبث
بالتسجيل تكون فيها نهايات الانظمه ايا
كانت انه هيدي بتداول السلمي للسلطه بصوره
دي انا ما انا مش للغيب
بكل تاكيد بكل تاكيد يعني حتى وان طالت
قليلا
[موسيقى]
كان هذا اللواء كامل الوزير رفعه السياسي
هذا الاسبوع الى رتبه مشير ومرتبه وزير
ادام الله الود في موريتانيا الرئيس
الحالي لم يرفع وزير دفاعه ترشحه للرئاسه
فكلاهما من ابناء انقلاب واحد وما يحدث هو
تناول عسكري وضع اه خطين تحت الكلمه عسكري
سلمي على السلطه بدل ان يفيق اه ضابط يطيح
في زملائه في السلطه العسكريه اتفق
الجنرالات فيما يشبه الاوليغارشيه على ان
يسلموا الرايه لاحدهم والشعب لادخل له في
هذا اه محمد عبد العزيز لا يمكن ان يعطي
دروسا في الديمقراطيه وهو ما انقلب على
الرئيس المنتخب سيدي محمد ولد الشيخ عبد
الله ومن كان بجواره في هذا الانقلاب هو
الفريق اه غزواني لكن هذا السياسي استاذ
وليس ولد عبد العزيز هو يمتلك مواصفات
قياسيه طاقه كبيره بسرعه فائقه هو محرك
مركزي للاطارات الناشطه مشعل الطاقه
البيره والسرعه و قرارات حاسمه كيف يسقط
السيسي وخطيب السياسي امام السياسه اضرب
يا سيسي فانت السياسي القياسي انت القاضي
وشعب ك راضي فان اناشدك يا سياده الرئيس
بالاستمرار في متابعه سيادتك مباشره
للمحاسبه الصارمه لكل محمل او تسيب يتسبب
باهماله في مصري واحد وزاره الاوقاف التي
قدمت للامه هذا الخطيب الاخر اطلقت للدنيا
اول مؤذن اخرى اقسم بالله العظيم ثلاثه ان
افضل قضيه ان فيه
في وزاره الاوقاف والله وتالله وبالله
اخرى
وما داخل والرشوه هل يسقط المصريون
السياسي ل تغتصب نساؤهم وتتحول الى سبايا
يسال عجبك لولا السياسي كانت مصره حركه
كان عاوزين
ستنا وبناتها
السياسي يتوعد المصريين بانه سيحاسبهم يوم
القيامه والله والله انا وانت قدام روبير
اسالكم زي منتم بتسالون
وحسب كم هي من طلبت حزب
بكل الاحوال فخامته سياسي
[موسيقى]
قال الجزائريون شكرا بوتفليقه ويكفي والله
يكفي فرد عليهم بقرار زين ومبارك فهمتكم
لم اكن انتوى الترشح
نعم يكفي لكن هذه ال يكفي اقر انها الرئيس
بتمديد لنفسه الى موعد غير محدد غير
الحكومه ورئيسها فيما الناس تريد تغيير
النظام
وكلف الاخضر الابراهيمي برئاسه مؤتمر
انتقالي يحدد مستقبل الجزائر قبل نهايه
السلام السياسي الكويتي ناصر الدويله قال
ان شاء الله ما يدخل اخواننا البدء في
تخريب ربيع الجزائر اليانع و انتبهوا ايها
الجزائريون منع ربنا لانهم سيخربون بيوتكم
الكاتب السعودي تركي الحمد وبعد ان كان
مثيرا للجدل اصبح وضعه مثيرا للقلق مع هذه
التغريده التي تنتقد ضمنيا بوتفليقه
والسياسي والبشير دفعه واحده فيقول هذا
يريد التغيير تغيير الدستور ليحكم مدى
الحياه وذاك متشبت بكرسي السلطه وهو قاب
قوسين او ادنى من النهايه واخرت زوج مفقود
تقول له زوجته لا احبك فيقول لها انت
تحبينني ولكنك لا تشعري
في الحلقه الماضيه استخدمنا مقطعا انتشر
على مواقع التواصل
اجتزا حوارا على الحدث يظهرها وكانها
اسكتت نائبا مصريا معارضا ل تحيط رئاسه
السياسي بالتسرع ب فقدان الصوت تبين لنا
لاحقا ان المقابله استانفت دون اي تهرب من
قناه الحدث
هذا الاستئناف للحوار مع النائب المصري
المعارض وضعه عند متابعا مغرض في دائره
الشك بدل تبرئه غيره سالنا الرفيق والصحيه
دقيقه جدا ومعقده جدا وهو ما
في وضع
السعوديه العربيه
هذا هذا اذا ما
نعم شكرا جزيلا لك كنت معنا من امام
المستشفى الجامعي في جنيف موقع قناه روسيا
اليوم عندنا خبرا بالتالي الذباب
الالكتروني السعودي يحرك تصريحا لوزير
تركي عن السياح العرب صرح وزير الخارجيه
التركي سليمان سوريا وهو نائب رئيس حزب
العداله والتنميه الحاكم في تركيا اه ان
اجهزه الامن تطرد كل من ينتقذ بلاده من
خارجها وانه وانها ست قبض على السياح منهم
فور قدومهم للمدن التركيه نتابع المقطع
اما المستهدف من كلام وزير الداخليه
التركي فهم من يصفهم بالارهابيين
[موسيقى]
اعلام حلف القرار اهتم بكل صحيفه صاندي
تايمز البريطانيه
يتحدث عن رشاوى قطريه للفيفا من اجل الفوز
بتنظيم المونديال
وقد بثت قناه العربيه تقريرا حول الموضوع
نعرض مقتطفا منه لتعميم الفائده
كشفت وثائق مساعد قتل مبالغ وصلت الى
ثمانمائه وثمانين مليون دولار
قبل فوز هذا اقتراع كاس العالم في 2010
وتظهر الوثائق التي اطلعت عليها صحيفه
الصنداي تايمز ان مدرائه فيينا في قناه
الجزيره القطريه وقع عقدا بقيمه اربعمائه
مليون دولار للحصول على حق ما في كاس
العالم في الفين وثمانيه عشر والفين
واثنين وعشرين قبل اغتيال الدوله المضيفه
للمتمردين بين الفيفا والحكومه القطريه
والاعلام المستقل اجل نفسي منحازا تلقائيا
الى الاعلان ومهم جدا ان خبريه الفيفا قد
اعاد ثقه الرياض بصحيفه سانداي تايمز من
ارشيف العربيه 2013 ما يلي السعوديه تكذب
سانداي تايمز بشان اجتماعها مع اسرائيل
ومن ارشيف جريده الشرق الاوسط الفين وعشره
الرياض مزاعم السماح لاسرائيل بمهاجمه
ايران عبر اجوائنا بهتان وتجني والبهتان
والتجني هنا منسوب ان من الجهات الحكوميه
السعوديه لصحيفه تايمز اعلامي مخضرم يقترح
عدم التسرع باطلاق التهم على الصحيفه او
على قطر والفيفا فحين تخسر دول ك امريكا
وبريطانيا امام قطر في سباق الاستضافه
فهذا يعني ان محاولات التشويه ستحضر طبعا
هذا الكلام ليس كلامي بل كلام الاعلامي في
صحيفه الرياضيه السعوديه
فهد الروقي
في العام الفين واربعه
وفي نفس العام ايضا كتب الروكي الصحافه
البريطانيه ما زالت تعاني من فوز العرب
ممثلين ب قطر بتنظيم المونديال و تشن حربا
ضروسا بمعاونه بعضنا الكاتب نفسه صار من
بعضنا تغرد قبل ايام صنداي تايمز تكشف عن
وثائق سريه ل مبالغ ضخمه قدمتها قطر قبيل
اعلان فوزها بتنظيم كاس العالم
برنامج في قناه سعودي اربعه وعشرين يدافع
عن تقاعس الامارات في تحرير جذورها التي
تحتلها ايران يحاججون ينافسون
يشمتون بالامارات انتم انتم محتله طيب اه
يعني اه جيش جيوشكم احتلوها لا لا هذا لا
يجوز يعني هذا هذا يعني
دول الدول العاقله الدول المحترمه تتجنب
الحروب وهل تتجنب الدول العاقله حروب
تحرير ارضها من المحتل لتذهب فتحارب لتحتل
ايضا في دوله مجاوره اسمعوا المحافظه
اليمني من فريق الرئيس هادي صالح سميع
ماذا يقول ثلاثين مليون بني ادم داخل هذا
الوطن هم امانه في علاج عبد ربه منصور
هادي وفي الملك سلمان خادم الحرمين
الشريفين وهو حقيقه لم يطلب الا لدعم
المملكه العربيه السعوديه لم يطلب احد اخر
لكن هم عملوا تحالف وجابوا معهم هذا طرف
الارهاب الذي يتصرف تتصرف الغربي فهي اخي
الكريم المساله مثل ما قلت لك وصلت الى حد
كسر العظم فاما ان نكون او لا نكون
نحن شعب كبير يا اخي نحن شعب كبير كبير
كبير ثلاثين مليون اكثر من ذلك صارت بعض
القوى الشرعيه تقارن بين ايران والتحالف
والله
ايران وشن هؤلاء الذين يعملون
بعض اطراف التحالف
لماذا لان
تحرك يمين وشمال ال ايران ليست كلها جر
ناشطه اماراتيه تخرج عن اصول النقد العلمي
والاكاديمي وتستخدم عبارات وصفت بالسوقيه
لتطاول على ماذا على صحيح البخاري ابرز
كتب الحديث النبوي الشريف على الاطلاق وهو
الذي قال فيه الامام النووي في شرح مسلم
اتفق العلماء على ان اصح الكتب بعد القران
الكريم الصحيح ان صحيح البخاري وصحيح مسلم
وتلقتها الامه بالقبول
في الامه امراه
والله صحيح البخاري
[موسيقى]
بعدما احرجها مغردون بان الشيخ محمد بن
راشد يطلع صحيح البخاري فكيف تصفه بالكتاب
المتخلف قدمت اعتذارا ايضا خارجا عن اصول
البحث الاكاديمي
فقالت قد اكون اخطات التعبير في الحديث عن
كتاب البخاري الناشطه الاماراتيه رفضت
رحمه اختلاف الائمه ضمن المذهب الواحد هي
تقول انها تحرريه لكنها ترفض التعدديه في
الخيارات الفقهيه
على الخلاف
[موسيقى]
في المؤتمر الذي جمعه بنظيره الروسي سيرجي
لافروف اجاب وزير الخارجيه الاماراتي عبد
الله بن زايد على التساؤلات حول اسباب
اعاده فتح ابو ظبي لسفارتها بدمشق
لاشك ان
من مهم
نحن في مرات حريصين ان
يكون هناك دور عربي
طبعا قال الكثير بعد ذلك لكن لضيق الوقت
نكتفي بهذا القدر من الاجابه لابروف اكمل
جولته الخليجيه بزياره الرياض والتقى وزير
الخارجيه السعودي ابراهيم العساف في مزار
منطقه الدرعيه برفقه وزير الدوله للشؤون
الخارجيه عادل الجبير قد وزير الخارجيه
الروسي سيرجي لافروف محادثات مع وزير
الخارجيه السعودي ابراهيم العساف وازال
بعد ذلك منطقه داعيه تاريخيه المدرجه على
قائمه التراث العالمي لمنظمه الامم
المتحده للتربيه والعلم والثقافه
العساف اجتمع ب لافروف بحضور الجبير
ومسؤولين لافروف زار منطقه الدرعيه برفقه
الجبير فهل العساف وزير خارجيه بدون
نشاطات خارجيه
بعد توقيفه لمده اسبوع قرار رسمي عاد
برنامج داوود الشريان على قناه اس بي سي
السعوديه فماذا يفعل في هذه الحاله الراس
مون في اعلام الرياض اي هدف سوى اداره
البلبله و وجود خلافات مجتمعيه طيب جميل
جدا المجتمع هو من رفضها ماذا تريدون ضاحي
خلفان مره واحده الى عالم التنظيم بدون
تمهيد يخترق ميدان العرافه من بابه الواسع
ليصبح
فقال نتنياهو سيزور هذا العام دولا
افريقيه
وقد يتعرض لمحاوله اغتيال
[موسيقى]
ختاما كان مريضا على فراش الموت عندما
دخلت عليه فجاه امراه اشتهرت بالحسن على
الفور وقال لها استحلفك بالله ان
تصلي على النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
وماذا
وانت بهذه الحال في اخر
الموت
الحاضرون الا تلك المراه
هذه التي يملكها
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
ام